haking max und herzlich kommen zu einer
runde jump league zusammen mit ja ja ich
noch an diese szene wohl so maskulin
geschrieben hast ein video in dem ein
video wer kennt das nicht
und ich dachte mir ich habe gestern
gesagt nicht schon wieder nicht schon
wieder getan und das ist gerade nicht
schon wieder getan
es ist schwer für mich leute es ist ich
kann auch grelles vergleichen ja stimmt
weil das würde dass der anfangs vater
sind diese diese ganzen bunten sachen
einkommen nur reden aber nur noch im
ghetto folge das video kommt richtig gut
an dieses ich bin süchtig video ist wo
ich meine sucht erklärt haben und alle
leute sagen
kannst du wie stehst du zu deiner sucht
was wir bei der suchtberatung durch die
plötzliche hier jump league hat
wenigstens auch was mit springen zu tun
und das ist halt so ein kleiner ersatz
so weißt du aber es ist natürlich nicht
nur fans an den server nicht das wahre
ich sehe auch wenn somit zu reden ja ich
hatte gerade meine seminararbeit
abgegeben beziehungsweise vor ein paar
stunden schon ein wenig weshalb ihr
klavier auch gestern schon angeschnitten
dass das ein bisschen gefeiert wird habe
ich krieg dich und es geht auch gleich
weiter ich mache jetzt nur noch dieses
video fertig aber auch schon ein anderes
weiteres video aufgenommen hoffentlich
gefallen könnte glauben was euch
hoffentlich gefallen könnte hat ich
kenne auch voll viele von den paar von
den parkplatz hier noch gar nicht ich ja
nicht weil ich spät zu selten konnte man
alles was mein bruder ist aber richtig
richtig updater drin weil das einfach
absurd wie noch was echte macht dass du
noch früher sagt nein immer noch der
also gefühlt immer noch jedes dritte
video auf seinem catalyst ist trump
vorne hätte hoffentlich sei erst dabei
aktiv war ja auch folgen
aber er wird schon okay was ist das 5
vollidiot fans aber was soll der scheiß
da kommt noch ein richtiger kag sprung
so was ja der mit der tu oder nächsten
so komische kauz von spiels über 1000
über oder neben nein nicht haben sondern
erst mit einem löwen genannt
oder vielleicht kann er einfach nur
sehen wie ich heiße da kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen es wird überhaupt
keinen sinn machen
was wenn server damit premium ränge
werden würde glaube ich cool endlich
geschafft ich hab echt lange keinen
blick mehr gespielt aber ich finde es
geht einigermaßen klar wenn auch voller
kirchen fingert also falls ihr euch
gefragt hat wo für die fragen waren die
auftut dargestellt habe und lenkt so
beantwortet jedoch jetzt mal die waren
für ein anderes video was ich gerade
eben gedreht hat das wird aber noch ein
wenig dauern bis dort war dann bis das
für euch zu sehen gibt aber ich glaube
auch einigermaßen bald das war auch für
uns etwas das ich angeschrieben aber was
mir zugeschickt wurde
man muss ab auf dem weißen abspringen
acht es wirklich schwierig hat dafür
ewig gebraucht aber es gar nicht so
schwierig zu gast in den sprint und
landers okay du brauchst nur den
sprintstars mit anlauf das auto schafft
gerade wie sie die ich habe schon fünf
versuche ich habe eigentlich ganz gut
gerüstet
aber weil bei jump league ich meine bei
get down unser aller lieblings modus ist
es ja alter der ist jetzt wirklich crazy
der einen strohmann ich verzweifelt an
diesem dumm sprung
es geht nicht
ich hasse dieses modul ich will diesen
sprung schaffen okay leute ist zu mir so
leid ihr werdet mich alle hassen dafür
dass ich es nicht geschafft habe
sein neuester man ja auch so im team
neben anders baumreste ja das stimmt
das war mein einziges kopf und zwar
ziemlich dumm ist oder anzusetzen okafor
nach darauf gibt da hinten gar nicht
steht neben den anderen
ich kann man wieder zurückziehen
was in hamburg wird es runter sehr gut
da vorne ist noch einer da an wurde
ach so ich habe schon gewundert haben
wir die eigentlich klingen gibt die drei
leben wirken diese tests man kann sich
auch zur erweiterung kauft nicht mehr
items aus der jazz schon kannst du nicht
mit diesem special geschichten ja ja
genau ich habe zum beispiel glaube ich
wenn ich leder rüstungen mache dann ist
sie direkt weiß und das tägliche reisen
musste ich ganz gut aber wer macht leder
naja dann aktiv wenn man nur noch jeder
würden finden ist ich kann nicht mit ins
inventar nimmt wird die automatische
wird es ein ganz cool ich glaub ich noch
nie hat früher der ultimative trick ich
bin einmal gestorben
weisweil games in erkner ist gestorben
franz passiert ist aber gut
ja also folgt zumindest so an sich ist
natürlich schlecht was soll der typ ist
gerade einfach runter kam er zu mir ich
bin gefährlichkeit dieser alter der
prius richtig gut wo bist du
ich bin da wo wir am anfang noch waren
mit seinem auftaktmatch platziert ein
herz zog aus essen zurück bleiben ich
hab nicht zu bringen aber mal ein
ausgehandelter richtig hast du
vielleicht reisen
leider nicht okay ich hab da hast du
flint ja hab ich kommen beide welten
ziehen scheint das auf den auf den typen
gehen
ich bin weg fragliche auch halter nur
zwei leben wo bist du bist uns damit ich
bin irgendwo weil ich probleme auf uns
zukommen ich bin da wo gerade gestorben
ist nicht einfach im team oben weiter
ich muss hier dringend weg die stehende
einfach so komischen posten zu zweit
rumläuft bin da wo wir gestorben sind
das ist meine nähe uns sehr gut
überlegen wie wir zweiten ja alles fein
essen greifen wo bist du denn ich bin da
wo der prämie spieler ist und mazda lp
oder so ich bin gleicher weil ich bin
der ruhestand geht auf mich direkt jetzt
grade mal eingreifen angekommen aber
anja mikus eindruck vorher macht zudem
mit dass man erst dann zurück wenn hier
hast du was du brauchst so stix nach
vorne kommt eine frau wir müssen es
schlau kämpfen jetzt es könnte noch mal
spannend werden 13 fall nochmal oder
wollen wir den anderen kurz ein team
ausscheiden wir sind ok das einfach
machen
hast du sonst noch nur falls ein
bisschen wir essen nur noch zwei kopien
aller geschäfte als ob er aus tätig sein
kann aber zurück welche über bussen oder
man kann aber auch über
hier kommt man gewarnt niemand kann auch
überlaufen glaube ich kommt ob wir von
der anderen seite wieder rüber für ein
buch darüber
ich backe im sound und ich glaube es
funktioniert nicht oder geht es
probier's mal mit offener von der seite
kommt eine den schnappen ist aber der
andere kommt auch wieder direkt altert
halbes ein herz ich hab euch beide oder
bis der einheit ab habt ihr noch einen
fall gedrückt gibt es ein bisschen essen
ich kann kanzler regenerieren
immer noch cookies okay du hast es nach
was aus nehmt mir leider nicht okay dass
das team einfach auf und ab und ab und
ab ich habe nur zwei leben wird noch ein
richtig taktisch spielen hier leben noch
insgesamt aber wir sind letzten oder er
ab drei herzen ja der premium group
leider aber erstmal abbauen dass wir
regenerieren kann
und dann lassen wir probieren das wir
uns vielleicht man es gibt hier ein paar
abgründe dass wir uns die vielleicht nie
zu nutze machen
ich sehe überhaupt noch im team ich
meine schon kräftig greift dann aber
nicht an dem ich nicht aber der ist die
ganze zeit alleine kommst du denn ich
bin noch hier bin ich nach mainz ist
eine führende auf den gold ich habe dem
ich hab' ich hab den vierer combo hab
den goldtiteln überlegt ab hau ab
richtig schön wir haben beide nur ich
hab ich habe kerzen nicht ist war es war
vorher nicht einfach in buer geschossen
ja ich hab ne ich hab' ich hatte nämlich
ihrer kommr eingedrückt ist klasse und
ich habe den bogen der schreib dating
ich komme von der anderen seite
ebay meist bleibt bistums überhaupt
nicht doch perfekt kammer und da ist
einmal die rennjury finger nochmal
geholt erst danach ein leben an der
meisten herzen gut das haben wir einmal
gut gemacht so intensiv mit dem du
suchen noch mal machen wir unser großes
finale
so gewinnt man nicht jetzt team anders
wir haben nirgendwo angegeben dass wir
ein team sind stimmt hier gibt's hier
liefen dann beide zusammen weil wir so
toll teamwork gemacht hat oder er das
mit den scannern und glauben experten
ermittelt die op die mittel ist 24 was
steht was wenn euch jetzt die kunden
logischerweise es den anderen besser
wird das probieren in die mitte zu
rennen in den letzten paar sekunden
denken gehören
du hast gewonnen aber das war ein team
gewinnen ein team sie keine ahnung weiß
relativ lang aber es kam mir kurz vor
weihnachten gemacht hat checa franz aus
in der beschreibung wenn ihr ein paar
tolle minecraft videos sehen wollt und
da sehen wir wieder macht's gut und bist
du nicht